there's a wonderful series of books by
gingery book one is how to make a
charcoal furnace and at the end of book
Seven you have a machine shop
so it's it it's sort of how how you do
your own personal Industrial Revolution
uh isru is what NASA calls in-situ
resource utilization and that's how do
you go to a planet and create a
civilization uh isru has essentially
assumed gingery you go through the
Industrial Revolution and you create the
inventory of a hundred thousand
resistors what we're finding is the way
you the minimum building blocks for a
civilization is
roughly 20 parts so what's interesting
about the amino acids is they're not
interesting they're hydrophobic or
hydrophilic basic or acidic they have
typical but not extremal properties but
they're good enough you can combine them
to make you
so what this is leading towards is
technology doesn't need enormous Global
Supply chains it just needs about 20
properties you can compose to create all
technology as the minimum building
blocks for a technological civilization
so there's going to be 20 basic building
blocks based on which the self
replicating assemblers can work right
and I say that not philosophically just
empirically sort of that's that that's
where it's heading and
yeah that I like thinking about how you
bootstrap a civilization on Mars that
problem there's a fun video on bonus
material for the movie where where with
a neat group of people we talk about it
because it has really profound
implications back here on Earth about
how we live sustainably
what is that Civilization on Mars looks
like that's using a isru that's using
these 20 building blocks and does
self-assembly yeah go through primary
secondary tertiary quaternary
um you know you you extract properties
like uh conducting insulating
semiconducting uh magnetic uh dielectric
flexural these are the kind of you know
roughly 20 properties
um with those
those are enough for us to assemble
logic
and they're enough for us to assemble
actuation
um with logic and actuation we can make
micro robots
the micro robots can build bigger robots
um the bigger robots can then take the
building block materials and make the
structural elements that you then do to
make construction and then you boot up
through the stages of a technological
Civilization by the way where in the
span of logic and actuation to the
sensing come in oh I skipped over that
but my favorite sensor is a step
response so if you just make a step and
measure the response to the electric
field
that ranges from user interfaces to
positioning to material properties and
if you do it at higher frequencies you
get chemistry and you can get all of
that just from a step in an electric
field so for example once you have time
resolution in logic something as simple
as two elect roads let you do amazingly
capable sensing